thank you
very much
again
foreign
[Music]
president
uh
Elizabeth
foreign
especially in the year where we
celebrate the 60th anniversary of our
diplomatic relations
EU career relations have come a very
long way a successful way but there's
still more we can do together and that's
why we're here today
I think our discussions today will lay
the foundations for closer ties
to build a more secure and prosperous
future for our people
and I hope today we will take important
steps forward to strengthen our
relations in the green health and
digital ears
the steps will help us deliver better
waiting to switch to renewable energy
and our being partnership
a health Corporation to strengthen our
abilities abilities to respond to health
crises
and of course we will deepen our
cooperation on AI high performance
Computing and semiconductors
I had this morning the opportunity to
meet the European business in Korea an
excellent meeting where I'm happy to
report to you that they were full of
praise
for the outstanding cooperation with the
Korean government and the Korean people
so I thank you for that we are strategic
Partners we share values and common
goals and that is why this partnership
in particular is important in the
current geopolitical context we've just
come from the G7 in Hiroshima and it was
very important to have you there because
Republic of Korea is an important
partner for us the European Union as
well as for the G7
and in Hiroshima we stood together in
defense of the international rules-based
order and the principles of the UN
Charter
and whether it is in Europe in the
Korean Peninsula the in the Pacific or
anywhere in the world international law
must be upheld and we will not accept
that that might makes right
the lifeblood of our partnership is the
13 year old free trade agreement between
us it has brought many benefits to
companies and people I'm looking forward
to our Summit today